57,000 اسره في محافظه مارب بحاجه ماسه
الى الغذاء ارقام الجوعه تتصاعد في احد
اكبر تجمعات النزوح في العالم ومعونات
غذائيه من برنامج الغذاء العالمي لا تغطي
الاحتياجات بل انخفضت في كمياتها وقيمتها
الغذائيه كما تناقصت اعداد المستفيدين من
كشوف المنظمه الامميه
النازحون والمجتمع والمضيف كلهم سواء في
المعانات
خففه من شدتها مشروع الامن الغذائي الذي
وفره مركز الملك سلمان للنازحين والمجتمع
المضيف في مارب المشروع على الامن الغذائي
الذي تم تنفيذه خلال العام كامل استفاد
منه
15,67
نامل ان يستمر هذا المشروع همم لملمسناه
من اثر في في اوساط المجتمع المضيف والاسر
الناجحه الذين يعانون من اعدام الامن
الغذائيه
مركز الملك سلمان الذي قدم الكثير من
النازحين وهذا الكراتين تعتبر همم المعنى
الكبيره اللي انا ابعد الله عز وجل
نعمه ناجحه من محافظه الحديده الى مارب
تعيش واطفالها في خيام مهترئه ظروفا صعبه
بعد وفاه زوجها توفر هذه المعونات
الغذائيه المقدمه من مركز الملك سلمان
قوتهم الوحيد وهو حال غيرها من الاسر التي
فقدت معيلها او من لم تلتفت اليه من
المنظمات خارج مخيمات النزوح احنا من
استلمنا هذا العالميه اللي سلموها شهريا
وليس المهنه اي شيء بس احنا عايش على
القناه هذه اللي اسمهم الملك سلمان
وعايشين عليها يعني ما حد يسلم اي شيء
كامل استفاده من المساعدات اكثر من 15 الف
اسره نازحه من خمس محافظات يمنيه الى مارب
ما خفف من ازمه الغذاء وهو ما دفع الجهات
المعنيه للمطالبه بتمديد المشروع وزياده
عدد المستفيدين ازمه في الغذاء يشهدها
النازحون والمجتمع المضيف في محافظه مارب
خلال السنوات الاخيره لكن مشاريع مركز
الملك سلمان وفرت الامن الغذائي للكثير من
الاسره محمود الحميدي العربيه مارب